yeah we're on youtube
right okay good morning everybody
um committee and officers
uh good morning to those who are joining
us on youtube
for a meeting of the licensing committee
wednesday the 27th of
january right we'll kick off the agenda
with apologies
for absence please thank you chair i've
received apologies from councillor
bright with
councillor cottle hunkin substituting
and apologies from councillor mackenzie
okay thank you um do we move on to the
minutes pages three to five
um i think it's rather a long time ago
um but we'll go through the pages
um at the top of the page page one
page two page three
can i sign them as a true and correct
uh oh chair sorry um
you're going on a different number
scheme for me sorry um
okay well if you haven't got the numbers
at the top of the pages
the borrowing page numbers are three
four and five
oh yeah it's three at the top there's
some
yeah i raised something about electric
charging points and
it was the reply was it was dependent on
um
a future high street fund project but as
that's now
not going ahead and just um presumably
there be some
further arrangement about charging
points
if we could agree the minutes first
council haims and then i'll come back to
anything
all right okay
so another proposal do we adopt those
minutes
uh councillor pose right i'll second
them
um so that's okay right so we'll go back
to
anything that is arising on them please
i'm sorry yes tom i'm so used to being
in that room
right kirsty sorry can you do a vote
please
thank you chair councillor bushby
not president it's not obviously yeah
thank you
councillor clark
councillor hunking
thank you councillor james or
councillor mcgoff not present
thank you councillor wiseman i'll
abstain
thank you so that's three four and three
abstentions chair
right okay thank you so we will move on
to anything horizon
um if we um
if i take up councillor haynes's point
we are having a meeting
about um the high street funding and
where we go from
where we are um i i
i don't want to say too much about it
but obviously disappointed we didn't get
it
but there since it wasn't that the
scheme wasn't good it was to do with the
financial uplift um because we had to
purchase properties
um in north devon's case basketball
some of the property was already owned
by the council
so any financial uplift did actually
come up quite quickly
so we will be looking again at what
we're going to do there
and obviously that will be um can be
brought up as part of what we're going
to do to increase the
charging points okay counselor holmes
thank you sir thank you good morning
councilman
few minutes later that's all right we
we've just agreed the minutes
and just doing anything horizon that
anybody wanted to raise
councillor haynes council haynes has
just raised
the issue that the uh the high street
um the high street funding that we were
looking for
um there was a provision for some
electrical charging points
obviously we're gonna have a meeting
about it
um and that would probably clear up okay
right
so uh going back to the agenda
declaration of interest
we have no part two urgent matters
brought forward by
the chair or any of the committee i've
got nothing uh
chris have you got anything no no no
nothing
thank you all right so we will move on
to the statutory taxi
and by higher vehicle standards pages
6 to 55 hoping you've got the same
numbers
okay thank you chair um yes
back in july the
department of transport released some
new
standards and called the statutory taxi
and private hire vehicle standards
and they released this under section
11177 of the police and crime act
2017 which enables the secretary of
state for transport
to issue statutory guidance to all local
authorities
who are exercising licensing functions
and the primary objective of these
of these standards is to protect
children and vulnerable
individuals who are over 18 from harm
when using these services
the department had a extensive
consultation with the trade regulators
and safety campaign groups and
issued this guidance as i said on on the
20th of july
all local authorities are expected to
publish their consideration of the
recommendations and measurements and
measures in the standards
the department of transport will be
monitoring all authorities and expects
all the recommendations and measures to
be implemented
unless there is a compelling local
reason not to
um an assessment has been made by the
council of the current position in
relation to the recommendations of
measures
contained in the standards and includes
proposed actions
which um is a pen in a penny
at the last licensing meeting which was
way back on the 11th of march 2020 it
was agreed that um
we would consult on reviewing the
existing taxi policy
this was delayed due to the pandemic um
and obviously with these standards
coming in since that meeting it
made it um an opportune moment really to
to hold back on that consultation and
include these
standards as part of a new consultation
um so that's covered in the next report
but this
report at the moment just concentrates
on these standards
um as you can see the standard's quite
lengthy document the
assessment we've done is quite electric
document
so i don't propose to go in through it
word by word but i will
highlight some of the key points that we
will need to consider
um so if we start on i think it's page
eight um it should be page eight which
is the statutory taxi
standards assessment um so i'll just run
down
the numbers in the column on the left
hand side
um so the first couple number one and
two
is just to highlight to to the committee
that the department expects these
recommendations to be implemented
unless there is a compelling reason not
to and
in number two given that the standards
have been set directly to address the
safeguarding of the public
and potential impact of failings in this
area the importance of thoroughly
considering these standards cannot be
overstated
so basically they're saying that we need
to
implement this unless we can demonstrate
there's a compelling local reason why we
don't implement
implementation and the standards are
obviously brought in
with safeguarding in mind um
point three is in the interest of
transparency all licensing authorities
should publish their consideration of
the standards
um which we intend to do once it's been
approved through committee we can then
then publish our consultation document
we they haven't given us a specific time
scale in which to implement
um all these recommendations but they do
want to plan so we've got the initial
plan
um and we'll as part of the consultation
period we can then determine what
periods i've put some
um some basic time scales in in the last
column there
that these are into negotiation when we
start consulting with the trade
um so moving on to the next page
which is page nine um number 10
which is halfway down um any changes in
licensing requirements should be
followed by a review of the licenses
already issued
this is not common practice at the
moment so that is something we would
need to consider
what this basically means is if we
change
something in the policy we then need to
go back and look at previous
people who've already got a license so
just for instance if we
currently had a period of seven years
before we'd issue a license if someone
had done a particular
criminal conviction and we changed that
to 10 years
we would then have to go back to
existing applicants and see if there's
anybody that falls in that seven to ten
years that we have granted a license to
under the new scheme we wouldn't grant a
license to obviously this may have
implications if someone's had the
license for
eight years and they've had no problems
or if anything
should we be then revoking their license
just because we've changed our policy
um obviously we don't know at the moment
we don't know what
um licensees that would affect um but it
would be something we'd have to review
and possibly bring back to committee if
there are
any significant issues with that um
moving on to number 11
um subscription to the dbs update
service
allows the authority to check online
at the moment to undertake a dbs
check we do them every three years at
the moment
and if they don't sign up to the update
service what we need to do is get them
in and they've got to
have documents to prove who they are and
where they live and that sort of thing
so it is a lot lengthier um
process if they're not signed up to the
update service
that we have allowed people to do but we
haven't enforced it this
the standards here are implying that we
should be getting everybody to do it
um because in cost wise it will actually
be less
less costs of the to the licensees
because it's 13 pounds a year
um and at the moment we charge them just
under 50 pounds every three years
so there would be a slight saving anyway
so again i don't think that's
too much too onerous on them
to do number 12 down the bottom there
licensing authorities should maintain
close links with the police to ensure
effective or efficient
information sharing protocols
we do have links with the local police
and we do
find out about certain incidents but
there are occasions where other licensed
authorities have taken action against
particular
drivers and later found out that they
had been charged with something that
the authority wasn't informed about but
that's something we do need
to review information sharing protocols
with the police
and we're proposing to do that as a as a
group the devon licensing officers we
have a group meeting
um and we propose to to take that
forward as a group
um so that's 12. just before i move on
rather than knowing to jump back to
anything if anybody
if you want to make a raise a point on
anything can you just interrupt or raise
your hand or
any sort of thing um so i'll just pause
a minute is there anybody who wants to
raise anything
so far um nobody has put a hand up
i was i just made a note of two things
because one was
the liaison with other authorities um
and uh um you know i presume we do we
have a working relationship with north
devon that would be our nearest
yes we do yes yes and we will be working
with them
i we have a regular zoom meeting
with all devon local authorities and we
do
obviously discuss a lot of common common
elements
um so we are we will be working together
with the implementation of this
and then and the other one i was going
to raise just briefly was
um the three years um the [ __ ]
i read that we've been doing five years
but um
we're going to do three but it would be
better to do annually
um and i think you covered that in
number 12.
so oh is that number 11 isn't that yeah
there's number 11 sorry
yeah i'll go on to checks there's and
there's another section of it later on
which talks about time scales
okay um so i'll cover that a little bit
later on because it's actually six
months they're recommending now so we're
currently doing
three years and they're recommending
that we should be checking every six
months
which would again obviously it's a bit
of a
burden on us but if they sign up to the
update service the actual system of
doing it is far easier because all we
need to do is get a check code from them
so we can run that pretty quickly
whereas if they don't sign up to the
upstate service they're gonna have to
come in every six months and
and obviously it's gonna be 50 pounds a
check as well so it is quite
imperative that they sign up for the
update service some authorities are
mandating
it and we haven't at this stage but it
might be something we want to consider
um is whether we mandate it or
or not okay i can't say anything
so 13 is licensed holders should
request we should be required to notify
the
licensing authority within 48 hours of
any arrest or
charge or anything our currently the
current policy is seven days
so accounts of problems changing that to
48
hours so we know much quicker if there
are any
arrests or charges or anything
and 14 a decision to refuse or revoke a
license as an individual is 40
harm should be referred to the dbs we do
do it it's not actually specified in our
policy but we will include that we would
do that anyway but it's not so that we
need to be
added 15 is again about police
liaising with the police and information
which i've already covered
and so moving on to the next page
17 tools such as nr3 should be used by
licensing authorities to share
information on a more consistent basis
the nr3 database is currently
a database which allows authorities to
enter
any records of drivers they refuse to
issue a license to
at the moment there is no central
database
but on our application forms we do say
have you been refused
a license from any other local authority
obviously we've got to rely on what they
say there
whereas with this database we can check
the database for any driver to see if
they've been refused
by any other local authority because it
could be a case where someone
applies for a license in london say
they're refused they could then come
down here and try and get a license down
here and if they didn't declare it we
wouldn't know that they had been refused
with this database we can check on the
database and it would
clearly say on there that they have been
refused
something uh coaching bush be raised in
a previous
meeting yeah yeah he did raise that
whether we are asking it on the forum
and we are
but so this is another another safe
check now that
if they did lie on the forum basically
we would be able to to find out
as it's at the moment we wouldn't
necessarily be able to find that out
okay okay so
the next number 18 is regarding
complaints
um a complaint system we do have a
complaint system we do record it
it's just that it's not particularly
easy to pull off stats and
we have to sort of look through records
so really it's just a
an admin exercise to improve our
actual reporting from our complaint
system so we can easily pull out and
identify any training
trends and things like that so that's
not too
onerous moving down to
21. sure so 19
about um something in taxes to show
to um oh yeah sorry sorry i've moved on
i've moved on a bit quickly thank you
for that
yeah 19 is to ensure that passengers who
know who to complain to licensing
authorities should produce guidance for
passengers or making complaints directly
to the
licensing authority on their website and
ways to make complaint to the
authorities should be displayed in all
licensed vehicles
we have got our complaints procedure and
complaint forms and online forms on our
website
but currently we don't require
vehicles to display any complaint
information actually in the vehicles on
the sales
so that would be something that we'd
need to implement here sure
yeah i would be minded to recommend that
that there is something
in yeah something in place within the
taxis
yeah which we should be able to do
fairly fairly easily to be honest
so moving on down to 21
um all individuals that determine
whether a license is issued should
be required to undertake sufficient
training
as a minimum training for a member of
the licensing committee should include
licensing procedures
natural justice understanding the risks
of csae
disability and equality awareness and
making decision we do train
committee members um but it's where we
need to just review that and make sure
we're giving you enough training and
covering enough of the aspects that
that are required to so that's just a a
review exercise really and quite
possibly maybe we should be bringing
possibly as part of um the committee
which i've done before i've sort of
given us some briefing sessions on
various aspects of licensing
where we should bring in sort of
refresher things during committee
meetings or things like that so that's
something just
consider yeah i've made a note of that
question
it's been a long time since i did the
training i was going to say
the updates as we go along yeah we do
we do generally at the start of the term
we'll give
licensing committee members but i think
during the actual term of your
of your um time on the committee
we're not quite so quite so robust on
that so that is something
yeah we can look at moving on
to the next page and 23
again i've just touched on this
previously is all licensed drivers
should also be required to evidence
continuous registration of the dds
update service
to enable the local authority to
routinely check for new information
every six months
drivers that do not subscribe to the
update service should still be subject
to a check every six months
so currently we check all as i said
previously we check all our drivers
every three years
and sign up to the opt to heat services
voluntary
so we will need to consider whether
we're going to do the six months
which i think we need to have a
compelling reason not to if
we decide not to and whether we mandate
it
that they do sign up to the update
service as it'll be a lot easier to
process them
it will it'll cost them less money as
well because at the moment
if they have to pay 50 pound a check
every six months that's going to be far
more than the 13 pound a month
to sign up for the update service
moving on to i just can i suggest then
that if
um you know the signing up to the dbs i
mean it's obviously quite an important
um public safety issue there surely
something like that has to be mandatory
not voluntary
yes i agree so we need that as
mandate as a condition of holding a
license anyone that refuses to
clearly is in danger of having their
license revoked
and as you say there's not a financial
cost to this this is purely
a public safety issue and a safeguarding
issue
can we do that that councilor bushby
question do you want to come in yeah
that's what if you want to mandate
obviously we're going to
run the consultation exercise
[Music]
so we can as part of the consultation
exercise we can say that we think this
is
extremely serious and we've decided that
this will be
implemented unless again there should be
a compelling reason why not
so we could put it back to the drivers
and say well if you don't think you
should we should implement this
what's your compelling reason why not
and i think it'd be difficult for them
to find a compelling reason why not to
be honest
yeah okay okay are you happy with that
thank you michael
um so yeah moving on um 24
licensing authorities should not as part
of their policies issue a license to any
individual that appears on
either of the bard lists which we don't
do anyway but it's not specifically
stated in our policies that's just a
policy amendment there to include that
in there
25 all licensed authorities should
provide safeguarding advice and guidance
to the trade and should require taxi
and private hire vehicle drivers to
undertake safeguarding training
um we we did start that and
unfortunately covid came in we had
booked in
a number of courses april and may
unfortunately it had to be cancelled due
to the to the
coveted outbreak so we will implement
that as soon as we can as soon as it's
safe to start
um do we can i ask us what what form of
training would that
would that would that take place we've
got quite a lot of taxi drivers
and i can see this being quite an
onerous task
i would have thought something more
appropriate may well be
if there is if there is a small
to the point booklet which is issued
with some um you know with some relevant
information which all taxi drivers are
provided with
have to read it have to
initial that in various sections and
then sign at the bottom
and then re return it to you as a as the
you know license and officer at least
that way
you've got some written evidence that
you know you've provided them with
written um requirements
regarding safeguarding and you know that
they've
written they've read it they've
understood it handed it back and you've
got something on file
but i think you'd i think you'd find it
difficult
i would find it difficult to um you know
require taxi drivers to come into the
into the office or whatever either
individually
or as a group it's going to be onerous
on them it's also going to be almost on
you as the uh as the staff members
yeah that's that's a good point because
currently in the policy they do receive
the code of conduct which does detail
safeguarding
i think a specific document that they
have to sign
and say they've read is is a good idea
actually so yeah we can implement that
um moving forward obviously as things
improve we can then go back into the
the classroom situation so to speak the
trainer
has started doing zoom sessions but
again
not being you know disrespectful to some
of our taxi drivers i know some of them
do struggle with technology
um so they may well struggle attending a
zoom
sort of session so so yeah i think that
that's a good point and it's something
we can definitely definitely implement
quite easily
okay thank you
okay moving on down to 27
licensing authorities should require a
basic disclosure from the dps
and that a check is undertaken annually
for vehicle proprietors
this is people who actually own the
vehicle itself um the majority
of our vehicles are owned by drivers
so they are dbs through the driver's
driver
situation but there are a few vehicles
that are
jointly owned by partners or business
partners
so as it stands at the moment they they
don't get checked by us
um so the proposal here is that they
would get checked
they wouldn't need the full enhanced dps
check it just be a
basic dps check and it would be
every 12 months um
so again that's a thing that we can
easily implement there's not that many
proprietors that are not drivers so it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be very onerous
on us either so that's something that we
we will propose um implementing again
unless
they can demonstrate a compelling reason
why we shouldn't
27 so moving on to 28
is on the next page all local devices
and forestry
should consult to identify if there are
local circumstances which indicate the
installation of cctv in vehicles would
have either a positive or
adverse effect on the safety of users
cctv is discretionary in of
caps um some firms
um some authorities have made it
mandatory
and this i think is part of the
consultation process we can open this up
and
and consult with with the trade and also
the police is whether they've got any
evidence that in mandatory cctv would
have a positive or possibly an adverse
effect so
that will form part of the consultation
process
yeah i think yeah there could be privacy
issues there yeah there are there are a
wide number of issues there's also
obviously data protection issues
and there have been some issues
regarding actually who's the data
controller if
authorities mandate it then the
authority could be the data controller
and
then the if we're the data controller
it should be made that the the train
can't access it without our permission
of things like there are a lot of
various legal issues around it so it
would need quite a bit of
quite a bit of research and
consideration before we actually
move forward on that so it possibly that
when we isolate from the
standard policy and look at as a
separate separate issue possibly
london london taxis have screens they
pull across women so
people saying i i agree that
i think that's a step too far to
actually implement anything like that
particularly in the part of the world
that where we live
you know for a lot a number of reasons
some have just been highlighted
but also cost as well i mean not putting
this kind of equipment in it's gonna
there's a fair cost to do that
and that has to be upgraded and
maintained and things like that so
now it could stop people using taxes as
well
you know yeah okay
down to 30. um we're nearly there
licensing authorities should require a
basic disclosure from the dbs
that a check is undertaken annually for
private hire operators
um this is operators so private higher
vehicles have to have people running
their private
hire vehicles have to have an operator's
license
again the majority of our operators are
drivers so
subject to the enhanced check we already
have this in place that we do
check a basic dbs check for any operator
but currently our time span
is in line with the others is three
years so
under this we would need to bring it to
annually but again there's only
one or two operators who aren't actually
drivers so again it won't be
won't be too onerous 31
is licensing authority should as a
condition of granting an operator
license require a register of all staff
that will take
bookings or dispatch vehicles um
again at the moment we only obviously
have a list of dr
of a registered drivers this is the
people who actually sit on the phone and
take the bookings
so we should require the operator to
submit a list of those so we knew
and 32 follows on from that to say that
operators should be required
to evidence that the facebook dbs check
the person answering the phone
is dbs checked by the company and then
they evidence it to us or sign a
declaration that they've
undertaken the checks sorry
oh why is that considered necessary that
they might
sort of you do something unpleasant on
the phone or something
no the idea is if you phone up and say
can you come
and take me to the airport i'm going to
spain for three weeks
and they say yeah where'd you live and
you automatically know that for three
weeks that
yeah that might be might be empty so
then they can
um either go burglary or whatever
so yeah the idea is because it's not
just the drivers that get sensitive
information the actual call operators do
as well
it's a strong evidence that um that
happens then i mean
it has been yeah it has there has been
i wouldn't say strong evidence but there
are definitely cases of
where that's happened and hence why i
guess that's been brought into these
standards
um because the the department of
transport has obviously got
information that this is this is
happening sounds like somebody's coming
so where were we
too so yeah operators look like dbs
checks so we've done that
um so
next one licensed varieties should also
require operators or applicants for a
license to provide a policy on the
employing ex-offenders so basically it's
a policy of how they
deal with deal with people that
when they employ them 34
is changing the information that we
require people to
or the operators to record when they
take a book in
there's a few extra bits of information
there that is um
which the department of transport
requires to include which again is
not too onerous it's only a few extra
bits and
bits of information there um
35 um
it's a long i'm not going to read out
the whole paragraph basically it
wouldn't affect
probably only one of our operators this
would affect basically it means if
you've got public service vehicle
drivers
as well as taxi drivers if for some
reason you haven't got any taxi drivers
driving a private higher vehicle you
could send
a mini bus with pc pcv driver
to go and undertake that booking because
under quite a higher vehicles can only
be licensed up to eight seats
um coach companies for instance would
have buses and minibuses over that
um capacity so this basically says that
if they send a coach which is unlikely
to happen if you book a
quite a higher vehicle it's unlikely
they're going to send a face to coach to
come and pick you up but
this just covers that if it does
actually actually happen that they need
to
obtain consent to send a public service
vehicle
rather than a private hire vehicle
um so 36
licensing ferrari should where need
arises jointly authorized officers for
other authorities so
compliance and enforcement can take and
against licensees from outside their
area um we'll consult on this again with
the deal with the other devon
authorities but basically this means
if say a north devon cap came in
to billy food and started parking on
or playing for higher on the rank it's
not allowed to do it but because it's a
north devon cab we couldn't actually
take any action against it we'd have to
report it to north devon to take action
against it the idea behind joint
authorization is that we could actually
go and take action against it
um so yeah any cabs coming into our area
from other authorities
the home authority is the authority that
takes the action not the
authority where it's actually applying
its trade so
that's what's behind that
37 licensing authorities ensure that
drivers are aware of policies they must
adhere to this is basically a
points-based system we do have our
points-based system
which we just need to review and make
sure it covers every aspect and
includes the new bits that we're going
to include in the policy
and finally assessment of previous
convictions
authorities must consider each case for
its own merits we've already included
that
um actually there's no action required
anyway
so that is it in a nutshell i think
um so everybody happy really it's just
to make you all aware um
and now we can go forward to
consultation which is sort of covered in
the next
the next report i'm going to do really
ex-offenders i mean it's not a it's not
an absolute policy that we exclude
ex-offenders is it that um no no it's
some
again you've got to be fair and treat
everybody equally
um but also you've got to weigh up the
balance between
the seriousness of the effect the
convictions policy
sets out the benchmark where you look at
offenders and what under the
rehabilitation of offenders act they
give time scales where
rehabilitation takes um effect so to
speak
so we'd take that into into
consideration
yeah but a policy is never never says
never basically
um if the person
can demonstrate that they're you know
they've reformed and their
new character and everything then you
know they can do that they can bring it
to the licensing committee which is why
we have
here licensing committee hearings is to
is to determine
yeah um so the policy really is a
benchmark
for authorities to judge whether they
issue a license
and if they don't know criteria then be
referred to licensing committee
um for a committee decision so yes
it's not a policy is we know doesn't say
we never will
it's just to make them aware that if
you've got these offenses
we're going to look at it a lot more a
lot more robustly than we would
if you didn't have any offenses yeah
thank you
sorry all right we haven't we haven't
touched on um
vehicles taxis or or anything yet
are we coming on to anything like that
later in the report
are you talking about the actual
condition of vehicles and things talking
about everything to do with the vehicle
yeah
age condition everything else is that
going to be discussed peter
yeah well that isn't actually covered in
the standards the standards that have
been the new standards that have been
released only cover
safeguarding aspects with basically
drivers um
the next policy review will come on the
next report
where we're going to cover the policy
review that'll cover all aspects of taxi
licensing
okay i was just going to raise if we did
that uh
booklet like don't discuss that we could
actually make sure that the point system
is quite clear in there so drivers do
know exactly
um what the system is and don't come
back afterwards saying well we didn't
quite understand it
so i i think there's room for
uh you know making that a bit of a
package that they sign up to
yeah we can we can improve our new
driver package to be fair and
you know we can do it when we can issue
it when they renew their licenses as
well so we can do regular refreshes and
things
can i can i suggest then if i can um
a point system is good so what's the
maximum a low
allowable point seller driver as a lady
recruit
we say at the moment we say you can
accrue up to 12 points and then it goes
to
licensing committee okay well
i i think i think it would be in order
to to um
to try and improve the the you know the
actual
uh age and the condition of of you know
the
the taxis that are on offer and you know
i'm not one of these i think that all
taxis should be
you know 12 month old vehicles because
that's just unrealistic
but i think it would be fair to say that
if you had
a point system which included the
vehicle itself in other words
if you're if you're operating if you're
allowed to have
12 demerit points for one of a better
expression
if you've got a taxi which is 10 years
old
immediately you incur penalty points or
demerit points
purely because you're running an older
vehicle and
the older the vehicle that you've got
the more points that you
initially start off with if you see what
i mean
in other words if you've got a if you've
got a three-year-old vehicle
you don't get any points if you've got a
four or five-year-old vehicle you may
get one point
or two points and the older the vehicle
the more points you
you actually have offset against you
straight away
and the re the reason for that obviously
you know is
a to encourage drivers to you know to
invest where they can
in upgrading their vehicles because you
know clearly you know as
modern technology goes on from from an
environmental point of view
as council aims i'm sure will support
you know if you've got a
vehicle which is you know nearly all
diesels anyway so if you've got a euro
five
or even battery or sex new diesel there
are far
less pollutant than any of the older
vehicles
and you know there's that's that's just
the uh on the um
on the emissions side of things but you
know from a from a safety and a comfort
um point of view the more modern the
vehicle the better the vehicle is i mean
clearly we all know that
you all we all remember what it's like
driving an old car and i
you know lately i haven't had very many
taxi driver taxi rides but you know
in the not too distant past i used to
you know use taxis quite a bit and there
was a marked difference between
some of the taxis that you get in some
of them would be clanging and banging
and
you know for my backer and i i knew that
you know various parts of the suspension
was
pretty well clapped out but you know so
i'm just trying to introduce something
is there an opportunity here
when you're talking about the point
system to you know
to use the vehicle itself as a means of
you know reward or
a means of penalty yeah that's not
that's not the idea of the point system
the point
system is to clock up indiscretions
so to speak so if someone does something
wrong or we receive complaints or
they don't renew in time and things like
that so it's not real
so it's i think it's unfair to give
points to people that haven't done any
indiscretions it's only the fact they've
got an older vehicle
and it has been argued in the past that
you could have a
10 year old vehicle that you care for
religiously you change the oil when it's
due you polish it every day or whatever
whereas you could have a four-year-old
car you run into the ground and don't
maintain but that doesn't that doesn't
your old car would have points but the
four-year-old wouldn't when
actually the four-year-old car is in a
lot worse condition than ten-year-old
cars
that doesn't answer my first point about
you know the
environmental side of things because
clearly an old car is going to be an
older player
let me just give you an example um uh
volsa
or the um the dv diva
dvlc no they they uh
if you're an amut garage they
when they do their annual inspection
they they look at the
the average age of the vehicle that you
mot
well clearly in this part of the world
we're going to be able to in cars that
are a lot older
than what you would if you had a garage
in london but straight away
you get demerit points issued against
you
if you're if the age of vehicles that
you
that you test is above a certain level
so straight away even though you know
i'd never done anything
wrong straight away i had
demerit points issued against my test
station purely because the cars that i
was testing
were older cars so the government do
actually operate a system like that
yeah i think this is a different this is
a different issue to the point
system we with the policy which is on
the
the next item on the agenda is the
policy review with that we would look at
age of vehicles and emissions and things
like that and whether we put
restrictions on agents and things like
that
that's i think that's separate from the
actual point system itself
the yeah i mean yeah i agree with
councillor bushfield
um it's under a separate heading really
isn't it um
we could introduce a point system based
on emissions
and age of vehicle and evidence so that
it's been maintained
all sorts of standards i suppose but
yeah you could
i think that's separate from the actual
disciplinary point system so to speak
okay i think we have discussed that
before chris
about the age of vehicles and the
condition of vehicles yes
yeah it has raised in our previous
policy reviews yeah
yeah so it's something to bear in mind
on the
future reviews um so you want to move on
now then from
thank you
so basically really we just need
approval
of the recommendations to
implement as we determine
we've made various comments so certainly
i'll take those on board
we'll take those forward as part of the
consultation we'll take those forward
yes
thank you so do we need to vote then to
confirm that we we're happy with
what we've done because i couldn't see
any recommendation for it
um what did i get now hold on a second
yeah it's recommended that members
approve the proposed actions to
implement the recommendations detailed
in
standards right okay um i'll move it
doug is seconded
sorry don't no i'm just voting in favor
of you okay
well i expect kirsten i have to do a
roll call
thank you to councillor bushby for
councillor clark or councillor cottle
hunkin
for councillor hackett for
councillor haines or councillor james
or councillor weissman
that's unanimous chair thank you kirsty
right chris moving on next item in the
agenda
until the taxi policy
um as i just said the standards are
specifically looking at safeguarding
things so that's one element which we
can now incorporate into the
the taxi policy review which is the
wider policy which covers everything
including vehicles and and whatever
basically we want to include in
in our taxi policy so as i said again as
i said earlier review the current policy
was approved at the last committee
um but the review was postponed due to
covered and and the implementations
so basically i've just set out a new
time scale
for reviewing this policy i thought as
there's been a number of amendments
under the standards
um it would make sense to undertake an
informal consultation with the taxi
trade specifically first
um and do that over over a four week
period
which will give them a chance to respond
and give any compelling reasons why we
shouldn't
implement the standards and also to
invite them to
suggest any other amendments as we've as
again as we've mentioned earlier we do
need to do something
regarding vehicle emissions and age
policies and things like that we can't
just let
um have a continuous age of polit of
vehicles so
again ask them for suggestions that they
obviously
they're going to take into account what
they can afford what they can't afford
and that so
it might give us some some things to
consider
um moving forward so proposed to do that
between the 1st of february 1st of march
we then come back to the next committee
which is 17th march
and put forward that their proposals and
any compelling reasons they can
put forward um and then we can start the
wider formal consultation which would
cover a lot wider and a lot more
um members of you know members of the
public and members of the
trade and other authorities and things
like that which would be a formal
consultation first of april
27th from may that would come back to
committee on the 16th of june for final
sign off
to implement the policy on the 1st of
july
sure the consultation would be in the
form of surveys
on paper surveys or internet surveys or
we're going to put yeah an internet
survey on our website
um just
one specific thing on vehicles actually
i was going to refer it to the climate
change working group i know councillor
haines you're involved with that
we're going to refer it to them to put
any forward any suggestions in relation
to
you know green green vehicles so to say
points and things like that so yeah the
work the
climate change working group will form
part of of the further consultation
do you think thank you to um thank you
chris um do you think you'll reach
enough people just putting it on the
website
that's yeah it's difficult we will we
might do some publicity we try and do
some more publicity
and to try and encourage people to and
we will do some
targeted mail into particular groups um
one particular area is like to
disability groups and things like that
um which obviously use the taxi services
quite a lot
so we'll try and outreach as many as we
can
anyone else got any points could i could
i suggest the um
i don't know whether you think it's a
good idea but the bridge trust give out
taxi voters to elderly people
yes they do i'm not sure i'm just pretty
sure they still do i haven't heard them
wrong the informal consultation
will we get to see what that will be
before it goes to the taxes
or will that just we will get what comes
back from them
i was going to just send it um
out to them and then back to the
committee but what i can do
is send it to the committee i can email
it around rather than
a formal meeting we i could just email
around the actual all i'm going to do is
basically a questionnaire covering the
points that i've sort of covered
um in this meeting um do you want me to
leave
you i'm quite happy to liaise with you
chair on the content of it before it
goes out if you're happy if you want me
to
do that well i think the commission
should just have some guidance just from
me
or by the other committee members i'm
not sure but
um i think we just need to know roughly
what
sort of consultation we're asking them
obviously if it's too open they're going
to come back with what they want
and then we'll be coming back over it
again but at least i know it's going to
be too long windy we need to target it a
bit yes
yeah i'll leave you before i send it out
i'll liaise with you chair
okay thank you
all right so we go to the recommendation
then which is to recommend members
approve the revised consultation process
for the taxi licensing policy i'll move
the recommendation that's
a secondary second clark
all right thank you michael um kirsty
going to you again
thank you chair councillor bushby or
councillor clark four councillor cottle
hunkin
for councillor hackett
he's just lost connection kirsty okay
thank you
horses run off councillor haynes
paul councillor james ball
councillor wiseman oh thank you that's
unanimous chair
thank you right so
we go on to the licensing committee
forward plan if you've got anything
on that quest the only thing i'm going
to propose is obviously
the next meeting 17 from march we've got
the taxi policy to come back on
um and again it will appear again on the
12th of may will be the taxi policy
our gambling policy is due for a review
by the end of the year so on the 12th of
may
i'll bring forward the consultation
program for the gambling policy as well
um that's the only um major things that
we've got coming up
um to include at the moment right have
you had any feedback from the taxi
drivers liaison committee at all
i haven't liaised with i thought i'd get
this meeting started first
and approved through this now i'll start
the consultation with them
right because obviously in the covered
situation we've not been able to meet
like we usually do
um so i will open up that now we've
approved it through this committee i'll
open up the consultation with them right
that's right
yeah i'm sorry mentioning kovid is this
this uh
do we as a licensing authority have any
sort of do we do we have any initiative
that we put forward to taxi drivers
about
protecting their passengers and sort of
how basic health measures that they
should
they should use when they're driving
yeah we've sent them the guidance from
the department of health um and
there are screen you can get taxi
screens we haven't mandated that we
put out we do allow it um if they wish
to do it
um it's down to we've left it down to
them as personal preference whether they
actually install screens or not
um taxi drivers uh one of the highest
risk
groups apart from the passengers of
course
yeah okay right doug you want to come in
yeah
just a couple of quick points um just
touching on that that point um
i was under the impression that taxi
drivers had been told to
wherever possible take passengers in in
the back of the taxi
in the rear and the rear seats but but i
have seen individuals
um climbing into the front passenger
seat of
taxis on the rank which you know
when the rear seat is empty i think that
should be discouraged i think they
should be
they should be told you know even if it
means that you've got to walk around and
talk to them chris and tell them that
you know get in the back seat
wherever possible because you know
distance in yourself is is obviously
important
um so that's a separate side
um i don't see it anywhere else on the
agenda so i'll mention it now
but last year it was at least last year
maybe even 18 months ago
we agreed at um licensing committee
it went to um staff and finance i went
to full council and it was passed
that we um we establish a feeder
feeder rank uh in on the concrete um
hard standing on the edge of the
keysight i mean still nothing's happened
you know what why why does it take this
long
i'll have to chase that up and find out
why that hasn't
told all all that was waiting was some
signage
um you know to indicate uh
you know for the taxis to you know to
turn left when they come out
we went through all the all the force
and against
um of of having the you know feeder rank
but you've still got a situation
currently where you've got taxis parking
in the minor car park
jubilee square all over the place all
trying to join the rank
i know it's been quiet lately but
they're all trying to join the rank when
there is a perfectly
adequate place safe place for them to
join you know so
it's all been passed and i think it just
needs him
before you know before the summer season
starts
yeah i'll pursue that and we'll look to
get that in place as as soon as possible
thank you
go back go back to what council bushby
said about the covid thing
i read somewhere recently that you
should be sitting diagonally
um in a car and whether that's just to
drive on one passenger i don't know
but um and also to have windows
particular windows open i mean there is
uh
there is health advice on that actually
which
yeah there is we have sent them guidance
there is specific guidance for taxis
from the
yeah from the department of health which
we have sent to all right
um yeah we can send them out reminders
that's not a problem
as part of the consultation actually as
we consult with them anyway we can
remind that would be a good opportunity
to remind them of the covet measures
they need to consider
yeah but by the time the time the
consultation is done chris
i'd like to think we're going to be
coming out of court but what we need to
start doing is something now
like sort of today or tomorrow
you know you or one of your officers
needs to be over on the taxi rank
talking to the taxi drivers and tell
them exactly what it is they need to
follow
yeah it is only guidance though so we
can't enforce it well
all right so urging guidance then
yeah i i've read somewhere report about
um
trying to ensure they did sit in the
backseat i can't i get so many i can't
remember where and when
um so i i'm not sure is
whether it's any good doing a flyer or
something just um
ventilation is important as well yeah
but yeah we have given them all the
information so we can easily
yeah remind them
right yeah does anyone have any
else no thank you
okay councillor hackett called me to say
he went to a mutant clips leave by
mistake but he was for the consultation
so he apologized for leaving okay
thank you tom well i think that's
everything so
okay then chris we're close to the
meeting for me yeah
okay thank you